what's our full podcast welcome to the
what's our full podcast we're back
people for the real choices here o host
of the year - 17 - the - 18 at least has
partisanship for them
no challenger undisputed well much of
reason I hear man is out there doing
live right now and doing drug sales
[Laughter]
people now he knows he's a mule like ha
let's get pulled over this guy pulled
over he went to flip a pick up a guy no
no no I'm not going my box is the box
had a little seatbelt and the
transporter he took it to a address and
then somebody picked it up and then
that's it did he pick in it no
transporter you didn't see the movie
don't open them it's a movie now no
never open the drawer don't open a box
we took it and narcos Oh accessory
season 5 did he find a dank in there
before yeah he for a meth pipe he's fun
a little a little leather pouch with a
pocket and there was a bubbler there and
uh some math and a lighter he's the
governor professional he kept them super
happy burn your drug addict Ray Charles
off once you start buying a bomb or a
bar holder paraphernalia paraphernalia
for the drug you use you're gonna lose
losing that stuff leave it behind like
me man
once I bought a wallet after losing my
wallet before when I keep my money
inside my my pocket with my ID never
lost didn't lose it a strip club never I
never go the ID there that's funny
better than the baracy
man when you when you run in a money
there and your mom or your wife had to
go bring the money that pops well he had
to get the money for him to get out of
the strip club because they weren't
gonna let him do any good yeah but do
they what are they giving dancers on
credit or embarrassing what stripper are
you the ones who blow from our house by
the way yeah it was around the corners
no not there anymore
that's the old school was under the
bridge I was when like before hips rally
yeah but back in a day man murders in
the river la like chasing cholos in frog
talk to the river suicides over the
river you know what that amore he said
we're gonna cut that story as a clip I
forgot about that story that's a
hilarious story it's true what's up fool
last week we had Jesus oh yeah here yeah
man who's gonna play the he's gonna play
out Takashi 690 now he's identified
people were believing it to the relay oh
my god imagining him Martin said he
could be like a flight attendant that's
his new job and witness protection and
like do little sketches at different job
or podcast again so we have JT yesterday
last week and he talked about our gente
Phi which I resolve the episodes by law
spoiler alert oh yeah man is good I
liked it I laughed and these people
sitting here are the other creators here
though right away thank you producer the
director the Lynn David Chavez happy
late belated birthday by the way
and Marvin Lee miss lemon lemons lemons
I know it's always people always say Leo
say leave us know limas would be el mas
demos Lamaze blood moves lemons there's
like a very subtle my dad always good
for my case of I didn't know that little
lemons it's such a subtle difference or
even hear the difference oh that is the
way it supposed to be pronounced but
everybody I've met whose name is Lee
limos pronounces at Leamas including my
son's teacher so funny because my dad's
Marvin but I just I started go I went by
Bryan my whole life and then after
college I was like I'm gonna start going
by my first name not Marvin because I
was like Bryan sounds too white remember
somebody telling us something they're
like Marvin Elena no you guys sound like
an old Jewish couple this whole region
started out now on a web series - I
remember meeting you yeah we got coffee
where was it like like alamo america
there in hollywood somewhere yeah I was
like 2014 right or 15 or 7:15
yeah
yeah we started as a webseries we like
had like a few months to write the
webseries and we shot it it would be
like seven episodes and we shot it all
in Boyle Heights like all on location
back in 2016 and right as we're getting
to production America forever became
involved and it was produced and like
financed by macro studios like it was
like a whole thing it was like for us we
came to shout out to a macro I know like
they really put their money where their
mouth sore and and it was awesome and we
like got to tell this like story that
like we don't ever get to see very often
you know like we didn't get to we wanted
to make like a dramedy like a comedy
that was just like and get this to get
the Spanglish right because that was
only something that we never get to see
growing up we're like you know we'll
have like for me growing up I'd speak to
my mom in English she'll speak to me in
Spanish like so we're having like one
conversation in two languages and why
just see like those kinds of things on
screen in a way that we hadn't seen
before so they took it out to try to get
distribution for and then the network's
were like oh so this is a TV show right
and they were like oh yeah yeah that's a
TV show look give us a minute so we all
like went me and went back inside we're
gonna pitch with our with our producers
and it took like five months to do the
pitch and then went in got like seven
offers yeah yeah and now four years
later we have a show coming out on
Netflix every first Friday people
yeah that's Friday what don't you
reminder right now you can benefit or
pace yourself and like just a little
piece every everyone says do you guys
been I don't binge right show up Inge
you've been binging narcos non-stop
right yeah oh sure when I follow through
I dream about that
[Laughter]
oh my god I've been waiting they're like
yeah I want to I want to get into that
so because one of our stars is walking
sorta yeah he plays pop in the show
walking co-ceo who's donate though from
yeah Darko's make oh he's great it
intensified he's absolutely insane he's
like and every time he would come on the
set like everybody else like you know
stood up a little straighter yeah he'd
have to always see 11 12 oh no it seems
taller than me he just he's pretty tall
yeah I think he's taller than that
probably but he's so sweet I think
that's if anything he looks like so
tough because he does all those roles
all the time but then you talk to him
and he's like so quiet and shy and like
he'll say the sweetest little things and
they help drop really funny jokes all
sitting here like I [ __ ] like what
like cuz he's so sweet and quiet but
that's why we loved him for a pop
because we felt like are the
grandfather's that we know like they're
always at these tough guys and how do we
show these like a really sweet side to
them and and he really just has all
those parts inside of him he's so sweet
mm-hmm yeah like I mean like I we wanted
to just showcase like a different type
of Mexican grandfather on screen but we
haven't seen yet like because and people
are used to him as the donut though as
the el coche in loco like you know yeah
the nautical that the bad guy like he
was in James Bond well we went to the
met khadija woman for 20 words came out
and you got there little late right we
both dickens word production and when he
got there there was a whole night all
the workers from the back had come out
to get in like ya know cuz we didn't
know how like big he was until like ya
know showing up and the cooks are like
you know like leaving the kitchen I'm
lining up to take a picture with it and
I was just like and like I just remember
as I was walking up the stairs it was
like he's coaching locals here like I
didn't know what that was like right I
mean I saw the line I was like oh he's a
coaching man people love it spinning it
over 40 mm films right he's been in a
tournament and everything he's been in
everything such a bomb guy from yeah
Bull young we are from Baker's from
California
shout out to Bakersfield people yeah I'm
Bakersfield Central Valley I mean I grew
up moving a lot so I grew up in parts of
LA - but mostly Glendale was like you
know kind of a for what
the high school for a bit you ever know
walk so dark is a little bit south of
downtown there Whittier but yeah my
family migrated to East LA and then we
all slowly like spread out down south
commerce like Noah Cowan Gardens we're
all over South easily the bus did a raid
that i-10 you do it to half the
neighborhood kids all right he's turned
his life around
yeah I like to go to our neighborhood
just to hang out with you were from that
neighborhood and we never know his name
but we did call him Hardeen why is it
Gardens it's like you look around your
layout know some boys and they are moved
to Carson palm tree formerly was anyways
good that we I have always a little tell
Nick to Hawaiian Gardens right I think
which one you don't know what it like it
comes up here like what went to a
birthday party there wasn't a hey it's
like our neighborhood it might be the
only white telling the neighborhood but
it's in between Cara Haines all those
little talents there's a little time I
know what you're talking about good I
heard of it like a few years ago and I
was like where the hell did that come
from
what's your birthday part of their one
in a neighborhood you know that was wild
I growing up I would go there a lot with
my grandma lived there most Alamitos
liquid
no my garden grow but you know the rest
on right there they've been next to
Lenox and Lawndale and not there maybe
Lawndale let make sounds like I don't
know I don't know the next that well
yeah Layton Lennox is small they have
their own little library and everything
and that's right now Cypress not Cypress
it's a they bought I would confuse your
hair mount I would confuse it for that
College it's not just like a college
name like like the college sideburns the
college basketball team and they shared
a similar name
oh my friends it's like go gente fight
you guys want to write first of all you
said you didn't know him when you saw
his name so how did you guys get
connected and yeah so when we you know
the project started with macro and they
were like getting the ball rolling and
I'm like primarily a director and like
and they were like you can't would you
be down to have a writing partner on
this and I was like of course cuz
writing a comedy alone sounds like
torture so I was like let's do it
I reached out to we were both partner
programs that film independent film
independent organization that does like
the indie Spirit Awards and they used to
the LA Film Festival rest in peace it's
not they're not doing it anymore
but we had done programs through them
and so I reached out and I was like -
Francisco Velasquez who runs a project
involved and I was like you know I'm
looking for somebody preferably like
Chicano Chicana like somebody that's
from LA like that can fill in some of
the gaps because like I grew up mostly
in Bakersfield and then the only name is
sent me was Linda and like he put us in
touch and we Chad and we just had such
similar backgrounds like we just hit it
off right away because we both are
we're both first gen like our parents
are immigrants from Mexico my mom a
that's what the model is on Mexican or
Monferno both immigrants undocumented
for a long time we grow pretty low
income and
but we also were both had like these
film school backgrounds like this
traditional film school but we also
started working in digital so we were
doing like a lot of YouTube content and
like digital short form content and like
which is very different from like a lot
of the film school kids who have like
you know they think like with a lot of
money well we know how to be scrappy and
we're like we're gonna make this [ __ ]
look expensive with nothing I can cuss
right just about that great and so we
just kind of spoke a lot of the same
language and we hit it off so quickly
and but we were also aside from that
like the story we're both really
experiencing that because the whole
shows up about like you know there's a
lot of themes I mean one of the big
themes is about you know where do we
belong you know as first gen kids it's
like Mexican Americans of experiencing
displacement in this country and trying
to be never feeling Mexican enough never
feeling American enough and trying to
find that space and then with
gentrification that's happening in our
neighborhoods it's like you know it's
like the one place where we can feel at
home and then that shit's changing you
know and so we yeah we were able to
really dig into that and we just hit in
that word like the best of friends yeah
we did a lot of trauma bonding you know
we're writing the digital series it was
a lot like he really came in and was
like listen I want to do this needs to
be elevated
each episode needs to be like a short
film like I want this to be quality like
our people deserve that and I was like
oh my god like we're gonna write about
my Pinot's and it's gonna be good and I
had been trying to do that for so many
years and every door was like close
close close close close and and when he
said that and that we were gonna get to
do something that was from our hearts
and that from our communities and people
we loved I was like let's do it we got
into it and oh yeah we got close when
you say every door what before had been
closed closed closed describe what
that's like well and in what ways things
were closing when you'd pitch something
or with you like early on because I went
to SC for film school so I got my MFA
there screenwriting like there was a lot
of that it wasn't like right now where
everybody's like Latinos are so awesome
like let's make all the Latino stuff
like people were like you're gonna write
in Spanish now that doesn't sell oh you
and that particular script had like
older women like my des and my grandma
were in it and they're like you're gonna
read about old women no don't do that
like there was just like a lot of that
and then I worked for my digital company
had a client Univision and we started
founded flama their first
english-language Latino digital vertical
and oh my god so many pitches
I had like 40 different series digital
series that I pitched they're all about
nothing I was like I was just so
desperate at flama yeah you got rejected
there didn't really find homes for all
the things that we had like put together
and developed and and I mean part of it
I mean it's been long enough and they
shut down all right yeah I used to do
some like social media boosts for them
every once while they reach their wack
[Laughter]
yes they they didn't they were trying to
take a map but I think folks taking them
out like I don't I guess save this
bucket I think a Univision like there's
a lot of people at the top who are white
folks and the people working for them
are Latinos and so the folks at the top
or taking a lot of these things out and
it's like if you're gonna sit there as a
white man and pitch like this idea like
it's not gonna translate in the same way
as bringing the person who's created it
so there was just like a lot of things
that like you know to the digital space
to there's not a lot of money in that
space like there's not people aren't
trying to invest in quality content
about our people so I don't know that
all like went away but thankfully like
soon after that it was like I want to do
long before I want to get back into like
doing TV and film and that's when I met
Marvin and that's why when he said like
we're gonna do some quality [ __ ]
Valentina's I was like oh my god and the
macro was like we're gonna pay you to do
it I was like you're gonna have pay me I
thought okay let's do it so that for me
it was like a lot of that just like
doors just not really walking into
spaces where I felt like I didn't belong
like where people weren't really excited
about the potential of our people due to
purchase and view and and I mean we're
such a huge market but people didn't
know what to do with us mm-hmm yeah
that's I mean I wanted you to describe
that because we've been through that
several
pictures and stuff but it's funny
because it it went once you mention
Latino or Mexican family or whatever or
immigrant or or you have language
another language in the script all of a
sudden it becomes a foreign thing and in
their minds in executives minds and it's
and not always I mean we've met so
Latino executives yeah there's more than
that one though but but yeah so it's
surprising though that they just it
there a wall goes up that there's really
they don't they can't continue to think
about this product area she was like
thinking about Cuba this job
yes great to take a risk and that's what
the US Latinos are different from
Latinos in America and I think a lot of
times they would try to develop content
that was like but we are different here
than folks in Latin America and yeses
crossover but like they don't see our
Condor or they would did in for a long
time see our content as like something
that was a pit appeal to folks here and
I think with the show I mean the show
has and what we were trying so hard to I
was like it's so influenced by us as
Americans like the [ __ ] that we grew up
with like like the 90s R&B and hip-hop
that we have in the show like the visual
style of it being very like the
aesthetic feeling very much like
American cinema like it's like it's like
this is it's so we know it's gonna like
appeal to well the thing is like the
world watches American content it's like
why we I was like we're American
Americans like let's make an American
story about us and like about our you
know struggles with identity and all
that but I think it's so and we always
wanted to be a Netflix because we knew
like we're like well they didn't
articles and that shit's bilingual as
[ __ ] like I was like yeah if we wanted
to make it as bilingual as possible but
there's entire episodes that are in
Spanish and then there's just scenes
that will be in Spanish throughout the
entire series and because that's just
how we
in the bilingual we have a bilingual
world that's I we kind of live and to to
be able to create it and make it as
authentic as we could so yeah and I
think it's starting to shift clearly I
mean you saw a parasite one you know
best picture like this film for the
first time I called it you know that
movie is so the thing is people are
talking about oh everybody's in love
with Korean culture blah blah that movie
just is good yeah it has nothing to do
with it could be any roles are in that
story it's the story right everybody
matters you know what like parasite it
could happen like to do a kappa here in
America what is the limit what do you
guys think is the limit I mean you know
what as podcast like how what's the
window for spoilers where we like that
we respect that you haven't watched it
and now it's like it's too long it's a
movie that's already I feel like a week
or a movie I feel for a movie a week or
two and especially after the Oscars
that's way it's already it's our that
award season is done you're supposed to
have watched it by now
no I really I wanted to just get clarity
on this there's a lot of movie she's
hasn't watched I've been watching
everything and I'm over here like I got
to be like I can't talk about she leaves
a room when she goes to the bathroom
we'll talk during the Oscars I was
commenting on movies man
and when Little Women boys before the
movie no you know one surprised me like
when Renee Zellweger 1/4 wide heard
about it and I didn't remember coming
out the older people you know rooting
for Harriet hardcore that's just boy
anything but you could you read obedia I
didn't know that if the slaves they
started to turn around go back to their
house they got killed
yeah can't be spread in a secret oh my
god I was like well now that word I
couldn't take but then I get it makes
sense you know we're in this together
you know yeah but my Master's gonna need
me in the morning now I shot him in here
yeah damn I didn't know that matter if
you're too old or whatever man just
rough life
later than the East cause when she's
done she's decorated and people
commemorate her oh really reading I'm
not yet with it that's in West Nyack
there was a river where they trail a
trail as part of the trails was mad
we're like oh man I want to see that
we're about to go to DC next week
oh man should I've never been I'm
excited to show one of those stairs from
The Exorcist yes yes just have a cupcake
at Georgetown cupcakes okay walk with
her oh we're going with and it's time
for those stairs brownie and walk all
the way down you're gonna be like I want
to forget the bat master these are the
stairs I wanted yeah okay I didn't know
there was any movie shot okay well other
than like the all the political ones
that's in a fire bird at the reading
house of cards that was my [ __ ] for so
long that's exciting man you're doing so
much press yeah oh my god I like what
that our you pose you did it but when
you saw your poster when you first got
the before I came in said that arm that
you're always looking out for talent
that I'll be able to look at ever like
water-hating
like we was they are they're never gonna
put me in [ __ ]
but don't just stay there mouth stay on
your level man people who remember you
know we're always talking about people
you said that many good give me home Oh
Polly got turned on that day
oh yeah that was good our pilot made it
very far and people hope and we still
have a chance
that was network well I know it wasn't
my first choice you know the showrunner
yeah the show it was it was we pitched a
fox will say that well we didn't pitch
we actually were gonna do the pilot
there but you wait I want to see you're
so [ __ ] hysterical we were so excited
okay so you watch me dad I watched the
first two episodes and the only thing he
said I just was like he's really funny
let me tell you like we like I'm sure
you guys are used to this like you
especially process we like have been
making these episode we've been cutting
them forever and like especially with
the jokes like eventually you get used
to them and you don't laugh at them
anymore
that scene is one of the very few scenes
in the show that every time still cracks
me up like we were cutting it every time
I was watching that scene I was dying
and every screening we do before like
it's so great the one thing my dad say
so funny after Phillippe I did his the
Honda commercials the Honda Fit
commercials a few years ago the world
[Laughter]
came out all these like working-class
spanish-speaking usually Mexican dudes
coming up to you in the Sun God oh so
crude on the beach the guy walked up to
you I saw you in that commercial enjoyed
in Spanish I saw you in that commercial
how'd you get that he thought I'm like
you I look like you
and Felipe's like well I'm a comedian
he's a comedian no man like my dad like
can't stop working like the Hustle is
real tattooed on my arm no but like my
dad cuz like I just thought about we
were the first time I want to what the
Marlo with him I was like 20 22 23
anyways we're like on vacation and we're
going to this Beach like you know like
near on the like the Caribbean side I
went to my lab and we get to the beach
and there's the dudes that are working
there like raking up all the like the
palm tree leaves and I fell on the beach
and they're cleaning up I go I grab my
beer I come back my dad took the rape
from this for jobs everywhere we go very
serious like the same think oh my
goodness a second and then the venture
they take I'm serious and they're like
own up was ok boys Olimpica you know
like why did he do now
why do dads do that I don't know I'm out
too many legs you could never go she
could never get invited to have dinner
or a bar because I would have without
without leaving without seeing the whole
house worse thank you and take a plate
to go everybody else she's not the end
picking up car my mom matches what
they're making beds world
making beds she's warming up the fees
with tomorrow board their whole party
before they leave that's why they bring
her that's why I invite her six kids I
don't want to help when your your mom
said that to your nephew to Christopher
when his lady he was Christopher went up
to make his lady a plate at the barbecue
and he she was like why are you making
her plate she's asking him in Spanish
and he was answering her in English and
he said oh huh I'm just getting it for
her you know just be nice she's like
that's not normal that's not the way
that's not what she should be making you
ugly I don't know
no and Alex and Dan my brothers are like
one knows nothing she's a my mom was
like oh I don't I don't like nothing you
no one had ever questioned her she like
about function because I'm a girl and
she's just like oh maybe yeah didn't
your dad ask you to do there Marsha to
do your laundry one time when you were
all your sister back home or something
or don't do it yeah I can see here you
never know I like some men are like yeah
yeah wait so are we like do we look do
people send questions questions here the
Derek's got a few questions
oh I really love this equation so fun
this is doe oh yeah
stop staring and I'm like this is cool
just see people like talking to us what
why this is wild
I'm over here like I've been living in a
box if I'd where can I see the trailer
if they want to oh they can see it on
Netflix right you keep on YouTube pero
también if you go to Netflix right now
and you type in gente fied you can add
us to your list you can watch the
trailer there GE and TE like gente like
the people and then GE and te fi e dy
one word so you can add us on Netflix
now add us to your list now so that I'm
Friday when it drops I see stuff it
automatically pops up it won't shut a
single camera yeah well we want you to
care I mean I guess it's single camera
but okay yeah yeah but I mean I think
every single cam show now there's like
two to three cameras yeah you're a
superstore yeah how many I don't know a
lot of them what worry what were we
character I think Wow no you can tell
they improvise no yeah oh my god I'm
super sorry that scene it's so funny I
we were watching that scene of yours and
uh we're just that there's like the big
one it's so funny you're so perfect I'm
just over here like kissing your ego in
another comedian we're practicing the
whole scene Oh in our clock a dress you
know no in a room in a hotel room in
Florida we're going over and over how to
do it and then I thought about it you
know I've been in this situation before
the guy that I pointed out that said
this guy said it was cool
John breasted it was cool Hawaiian
Hawaiian guy there's no lines later I
told me a man thank you for missing my
name they put my naturescene
maybe you just lifted everybody it's
great you're like we're all coming in
together
like react to the damp in that show
dude that shows hysterical yeah what's
your name mom
Carrie yeah oh yeah only now shall we
have green actors I can see though the
good action films
yeah we're such a striking failure will
you stop member when you grew up with he
said you wanted to be like her latina
lady she was badass
Maria good oh it's aliens aliens aliens
came out I wanted to be in the bucket
Marines because I was become a female
character like that before first one but
I didn't nearly connect with her for
some reason
the way Maria Conchita Alonso was she's
just badass is it or is it
are you terian she's a second one she's
in the sequel okay the sequel she's when
when Ridley spin when yes okay I
remember she's what's her name's not
Ridley that's the director her name is
oh it's Ripley yeah somebody tell us it
had been she had been asleep remember
for all those years after that she was
on the space
they what and Paul Reiser's in that one
too Paul Rises the bad guy God you know
what he's an [ __ ] in that and tries
to get them I've seen alien a ton I
haven't seen aliens still Paxton - oh my
god it's the [ __ ] aliens in general Mike
also in a predator - yeah that's what I
was thinking of when you were saying and
I thought I was thinking pretty sure
it's just badass poor never signing up
where the president killed everybody and
she's just like killing bad guys and
then let the Predators see you that
she's brain and they all love each other
like summer camp being in your group is
it when you say bye they okay Mel right
- you guys was cool - you got those nice
ass blanket yeah it was funny somebody
who was it on was it you or know if
somebody else was on the crew it was
probably me no it's a woman and she said
she got the blanket in the pan she saw
the blanket and she was like beginning
goddesses blanket so we started
predicting and then he was like oh we
did it
Mikey with Adam on
I always said was a setup at night you
know our managers are not Latino their
blackened and lower she's white and we
love them they're like so progressive an
amazing yeah they're gonna crack up at
this but I was like my fan and then it
was magic we're like oh it's perfect
harvested Akula that made my Pendleton
[Laughter]
you did the photo shoot that was
separate that was your Netflix we did
the gift rattler the gift everybody so
what I was doing was I was cuz I got it
right before we started you got you're
wearing the day we got it that's what we
were wearing yeah I was wearing it
people kept pointing out how much they
loved it and I was like young for our
wrap gift should we give everybody like
we should make like one for everybody
yeah yeah and then I will see people all
the crew tagged as they go to the beach
over this everything's are like a hat
we're like some [ __ ] that you might you
might use yeah or the water bottles yeah
that would be a little different like
it's cool jackets are cool I would next
you know what I really want next season
I don't want to spoil it but what I
would love to you guys if we get to do
it I know if we get to do the season I
was like I really want to make Dodger
jerseys
yeah we have a like a Dodger Jersey but
it's Felipe's our logo for a company in
Salem though and he's it's Felipe's body
the face and it's a drawing and so we
have a baseball jersey of it and he's
holding the baseball instead the first
pitch you know consortium of
high-powered Latinos who are influential
well I don't even know if they're there
it's the same anymore but they like the
Wells Fargo's like the exact yeah it's
those people they get to they're the
ones who get to vote and recommend a
chance and like this guy Hugo Hernandez
who was he used to work he's all doing
right he was like a CFO he Salvadorian
yeah came here he used to work at the
Latino theatre company and their whole
board of directors were all these like
executives and like Latino and I
remember going to one of their houses
and Whittier Hills which I live in
Norwalk so with your heels I'm like oh
[ __ ] so we went up there yeah I don't go
here hey we went into her house and it
was like insane but it was like Chicano
like royalty because all her walls were
covered and like Chicano art and like
she had Charlotte from the hood for the
guy you've been to the house yeah
politics all filthy rich are they
disgusting okay okay rich but there's a
house under Korres act that's even
bigger than your house and I think they
get rid of tortilla family owns any oh
right Dora's house
yeah where do we we get to the house you
know
they do a lot of people know that the
Wiis are a thing you went to different
life no be either be y'all weeds are
matters guys donate to Huizar we get
there and they there's a waiting room
for the comedian in the mariachis the
white guy they hired to play the piano
and me and we waited they all AIDS I
could hear him while eating having a
good time yeah I mean it that guy I'm a
girl here was there everybody was there
wasn't it was a la Torre was there which
Auditorium cuz I when I one with you is
just a family in red sweater okay so
they actually finished eating they set
up a little table for like 30 and we do
our stand up me and fluffy if I go first
and no microphone man it was
embarrassing huh
and then in the middle Center to
Christmas curls while the guy played
Christmas card you stood there did you
sing along I try bro we don't live a
little tiny mic there's an intimate
setting very intimate man and I said
never gonna do this again but I need
three more time Derek almost anymore
signing Willie left is that the one
where the woman said we have tacos one
should know it don't work this was a
Latino house man they had everything
catered like they had a Mexican service
they had everything ever there were
people were rich man that kind of you
don't even look strict wicked you in the
eye
I saw this guy and I was I did another
show one time where Kerry John Kerry
wonderful brethren and I'm the man that
was there he was there too and tell me
hello you were a regular round boy
Herrera he's high society man what you
knew his name was his dad five Christmas
parties at his house with five different
type of comedians oh and the same same
house same year you mean every year he
has one a big one every year he has five
different Christmas oh really
five good business partners business
different types of when I went to a
butcher for a virtual Authority and the
other guy from the ex-mayor really goes
out there that's a trip so like do you
like is that the only time you have to
do stand-up without a mic no that
microphone was not a real I want to do
horrible quality shows and I will make
either he kept half of the money cut
that off - oh that like going to the
house that it was a I was young and I
had like you know had no money I was
going in it was like a board meeting and
they were hosting and I was just like oh
I'm in the bathroom I was like whoa when
you know when someone's bathroom makes
you like go like [ __ ] rich you're like
wow their bathrooms like black marble
like all from top to bottom and like
their bathrooms bigger than your life
yeah yeah and I'm just not used to brown
people being that rich like it's like
like one section here and the mariachi
stop talking like come in the window
yeah good this for the wake up and my
hair is a bit sad like sitting over
there good - I say he's like pulling out
like that that goes that'll be great
he got mad we're not making fun of the
piano player real girlfriends with that
guy that are archibald with his name
Roybal Roybal the other party political
family the part of their part of the
Roybal crews arrival of Huizar last time
or not Weezer the yeah what's her name
Gloria Molina yeah
I feel like she's been in office since I
was like two she was a commissioner and
another different stuff yeah like I feel
like like those politicians that you're
just like okay I know her
he just like always like yeah she goes
all the way back with wasn't him the
first black mayor Bradley okay you know
part of a career for Rita Moreno every
burner was tight with all these people
so every time we had like a fundraiser
for Archuleta
we did it a highly yeah man
did you just come to a shows they're big
fans you had like the mayor wasn't the
mayor of Gardena that woman was epic or
Deena motor apart the mayor of West
Covina for latina they were real nice
that's cool that's awesome
a real low-key man but they're checking
in Changsha that guy near tattoo right
or is it Miami Miami the mayor of the
mayor of Miami Springs yeah I know good
is Miami Springs in Miami yeah it wasn't
like a Kansas City type of situation
where it's like man actually Kansas City
is not in Kansas right am i wrong is it
Missouri well there is actually a Kansas
City Kansas and Kansas City Missouri oh
there's two
like separating city of Commerce
instalay and Montebello you make a city
in the middle it's kind of like
Hollywood in Les Halles oh just so you
miss one about commerce last night
there's a student who is like my
family's in comas like I have a ton of
family in commerce it's one of those
weird cities that people don't really
know I had to perform at the karma
casino time oh yeah steakhouse another
Latino rich Latino is Richard Martinez
who's the creator he knows he's Bambang
right now Riverside oh it's from those
pigs from Ontario Rancho Cucamonga that
Latinos diabetes that's somebody just
yesterday we're talking about cheetahs
only I was supposed to eat it oh hi why
do I have a purple foot cheetah but the
regular is too cheesy unless you know
buddy
ready for it oh yeah yeah I'm gonna go
for this but I with the tortilla Doritos
those are the old school wait oh you
mean like this tortilla I know they're
kind of taco bell CZ taco sauce all
right much more mild
yes
Doritos did the bag was wise and orange
wasn't cheese it was just it's like Taco
Tuesday Mexican chips I got you I got em
si mentioned that commerce have a badass
polo team water polo this water polo oh
yeah I went to college with a girl who
was from commerce and at Stanford and
she was in the u.s. Olympic team oh wow
you know the and recently you know how
to have the big-ass billboards now the
digital ones she I think she was on my
team for many years ago they showed her
photo and I remember meeting her ice
ever be like oh damn you're browning
you're from Cobbers and you're in the
flamin hot Funyuns and I just got to say
dozer really limited them and then the
guy who did to Rita's tried them at
Disneyland I was like hey can i buy this
recipe off of you flavors what do you do
to make it first one you know cumin and
chili powder mix or whatever you know
that sound like I remember learning but
in story of nachos because I [ __ ]
love not oh yeah and they right they
took a borders for the second tex-mex it
was like you're like a military base
yeah
[Music]
and then don't pass over there like
closing up and there
yeah well N and then ignacio nacho' when
in the background and you just won it
was like perfect
that's how he did each one very hot
weenies with Tati no way just put him in
a pot a divorce over that with my person
was why no no cook being a hot dog over
the fire for me you don't like that even
though I grew up vegan but he became
vegan I was not being
man watching Souls is vegan too but I
grew up vegan and I didn't so we were
cooked vegan hot dogs but we would cook
them over the fire cuz that's just what
we did because we were ourselves like my
brothers and I would buy ourselves a lot
so we just did it that way on a knife or
a Morten
and so I asked my ex to make me a hot
dog like that cuz I was I was like tired
I was laying on the couch and he's like
no I'm not gonna do that
and I said why he said cuz that's crazy
cooking on the over the fire like I said
yeah what's wrong with that it's like
camping or something we had the biggest
fight over that and I went to work and I
told everybody at work how crazy this
was he wouldn't make no note it is like
white trash or get over no but when you
did it at home and then the fork would
get off obviously the marshmallow a
little delicacy you get the first layer
had a problem the layers of the Marshall
I think that's great because you're
savoring it yeah man
Marvin Luther come together to burn
himself with pizza rose you said that I
was about to chime in with I'm like bro
every time I have pizza bite into it it
doesn't burn anybody that blue yeah it's
a race bro bro it's only been in the
last few years that I got finally got
fed up with like the ability to eat
really hot stuff I can't
same thing with cold yeah oh yeah I'm in
the middle kill me I had a friend who
worked at Domino's and she what used to
get it right out of the oven and I was
like years like super human or some [ __ ]
one of those dragons from gave me bread
baloney yes oh man we're talking about
you don't even need oil there I've seen
people put oil on it
[Laughter]
but ER
it was like them yeah butter butter on
flour I still know that your flowers
with your butter [ __ ] I'm a tortilla and
I do make tortillas from scratch if I
make feels like two of them before we
even sit down like I only made 12
because then we'll just be eating
tortillas on body for the rest of the
week I've forced myself where the best
vegan tacos for well they're doing they
do pop ups all over LA usually at the
other door on Wednesday nights in
Burbank but or North North Hollywood but
they are opening up a physical one eight
forty and eight one eight food we were
friendly Richard Chang to here's a spot
in Echo Park
okay he's Korean and but he was married
to a Mexican woman and he speaks perfect
Spanish a Juanito is is his note a
Juanita 2.0 is the vegan one that's an
echo park alarm rise will he make like
this vegan cheese he fell he prizes we
get bird and he rolled a vegan back was
lately and I'm like these are so good
like they're just so good like they're
delicious but lava you are that just
announced to have beyond me talk was
that one of our friends went over there
yeah
meet in the ready-to-eat try to get
healthier yeah what I meant when I met
Philippe 13 years ago 13 years ago 14
years ago no he has my milk he had soy
milk soy milk but that's because he had
he had always had digestive problems
with Derril busy huh interviewer 30 of
you oh yeah this week they have more so
going on and take it all in yet yeah
that was kind of work like since the
beginning I was like we've been working
too damn hard for too damn long to not
like be present these like next few to
enjoy 20 20 hit and I got that 20/20
energy I was like we're gonna we're
gonna live in this moment because one
like are like I don't know anyone in my
family's ever done this
hell you know and I'm like I guess good
yeah I got a limb I got I live in that
space and like take that in and not only
for myself but for my family I always a
treasure of my my parents too cuz they
they kind of get overwhelmed and I'm
just like no this is real this is
happening like it's gonna be okay like
take it in feel that this is your
success too we have that in an episode
we're honest there's there's an episode
where where one of the characters
talking to a parent about like this is
your success as well and like for me
that's how I feel like what my parent I
took them to the nutty screening because
oh no it's like real like I don't know
for me just feels I don't know so many
years of work not only the last four
years it's just the whole my whole
career like I said
doors closing on these types of stories
to have this come out and people have
such a positive reaction to it I don't
know if I'm good no no I hate it on that
first time ever no it's been amazing
it's been a lot of fun I also try to
because it has been you know it is also
a lot of work like we're like doing a
lot of press around then and like you
know jumping into phone calls and
meetings and it's like it can be a
little bit my
but like I keep reminding myself like
well one like you asked for this what
you [ __ ] wanted now you deal with it
and then but no but trying to remember
I'm like you know to the flip side of it
I'm like it could be just nobody wants
to talk about it and nobody cares nobody
wants to hear things so it's it's a it's
a good feeling to know that I'm like oh
man we did this and we were very
unapologetic and making this show and
very night very intentional about making
something we hadn't seen before and like
and that people are like excited about
it and like it seems like people really
like care and are excited to see it and
from the screenings that we've had
people are so into it and are paired
like telling us that like you know they
feel like they are seeing their family
on-screen that they're seeing that
specifics and about them and their
upbringing that like they hadn't seen
before and like if I was the biggest
show in society never promoted because
um one the one they weren't there to
attack him on it wouldn't really like a
promotion like if you knew about it
somebody told you about it look the
Spooky's on HBO's someone told me about
like that man like but luckily they saw
that promotion we're about the share of
it oh no where's really excited Netflix
has been really great and like corrected
all the white people a chance to find
out when we start the digital series
like my dad was off identifies gente
Anthony will be saying gentle fight to
so like yeah we're having to tell people
they know and if identified deal alright
I think they say it because they're
expecting it to be gentrified and you
see it and you see the end and you just
glance out it you kind of say again and
then yourself
my name is great to see
oh no with the bitterest series we you
set the dash in it like ahead they fight
so that you could see it separately we
lost it for the for the show because it
was easy for hashtag how did because
that breaks the hashtag yeah exactly
how does how is it have you guys worked
in broadcast as well you said you worked
in like short form and stuff and then
looks like intense well yeah because I
was wondering what it was like I don't
you don't want to air any frustrations
necessarily with Netflix but like was
how was it working as a collaborator or
as a creative partner with them like
what did you get a lot of notes or was
it did you they were a lot of
frustrations or any you know we you know
of course there was always challenges
but the thing that we loved about them
was they were always so crater tripping
they're very much like trusting our
voice in our vision yeah and if they had
notes you know we always like talked
about him and if there was something
they felt very strongly about we would
go back and forth on it and eventually
if we felt very strongly they were like
okay whatever you guys want like they
were really yeah they really trusted us
I don't know we had a really great
experience and there's different
departments in Netflix this was the
comedy department and like that was our
experience with them I know everyone has
different experiences no they're all
amazing Linda that's what I don't say I
know some people when shows in different
departments and I know a bit of similar
experiences
ours is awesome so so glad you could
make it matter because I busy you have
to be somewhere there's a hint if I'd
Instagram right yes Instagram Twitter
there's mostly those Facebook - but
we're mostly on Twitter and Instagram
actually I don't have a Facebook so I
don't know maybe they are using it I
haven't seen it they haven't been known
as much Instagram and Twitter but also
follow us but I work for fast if you can
Linda Eva Chavez David Java mind's eye
lol a moose al Marvin a nose
not Connecticut le Carnaval Norwalk ha
in California no hearing the guests
California oh yeah Momo Momo he was like
you're from Norwalk and I was like yes
I'm from Norway I was looking for an end
[Laughter]
[Applause]
of us sneaking into events yeah at the
red-carpet events really hard to get
into events Wow if you just tomorrow
introduced me to the hat maker and then
he was like I say hey man my moment you
got to be moment
check out Felipe and then tell Netflix
what you think about it keep it to
yourself we know we know walking from
Marcos there we know people
[Laughter]
yeah I said she's one of the real Boyle
Heights types that I get to choke to
about who she was
yeah please good photo here because
they're still talk and I don't want to
break up the show so let's okay
are we still are we still broadcast
tonight I'm a [ __ ] through it like a
people I've been through is loss higher
I do a show where we were probably not
solving of music dance deported we have
a final tomorrow everybody was in that
show yeah he punched it up like the
third season I think he did some punch
of when there was a dance recital what
they call we're going to find those
where do they call their dance shows I
don't know I think the battle
competition competition recital we're
gonna make it to the finals
we're having finals because they were
like a not a drill team by like a dance
team did parties like they were going to
the final they just did for every
problem that's all no the girl came back
a little run episode three leg lady she
came on our bad act like it was uh she
came in like a housewife yes thank you
really housewife all cm2 Rekha so again
yeah oh yeah
oh my god I want to watch TV with you
guys but guys watch at the bike Friday
can we is there somewhere here we can
hang on to phone calls yeah they also
have a seat yeah pretty exciting huh
pretty exciting Lhasa
what's up fool yes they see let's talk
to the chats it turned off shout-out to
Derek's Slifer Margot Sandoval Bondi
glass what is that it was albondigas
[Laughter]
everybody's trying to be creative
well we were talking about Cool Ranch I
forgot to put in my theory that I think
that's what led to American obesity over
the last 20-some years so it's a res no
ranch ranch yeah that's what I'm saying
Cool Ranch I say cool I thought you
talking about Corinne so I just reaction
general
you know the high school when that came
out was like 88 or something another
high school there was no ranch anywhere
like yeah oh there was with my friend
Emilio cuz he grew up in Monterey Park
that's where it was Hidden Valley Ranch
very far I remember when people start
dipping in Pizza over rings I think that
started when I first see that she's good
factory wasn't somebody somebody well I
think it was Richard Christian Howard
Stern Show he said he went back to
Kansas and then they went to that KFC
all-you-can-eat buffet KFC Pizza Hut and
they had pizza all over their plate and
they poured ranch all over it and it was
and I remember that one mix that you put
into sour cream had a they had a ranch
mix that's the first time we're talking
about yes the first one and then it came
like the liquid ring yeah my would my
favorite one was that little lorries
green onion broth yeah they still have
it that's how older ladies used to make
dressing they didn't see my in bottles
and stuff it was always just like
mayonnaise usually and then yeah and
they would put a little sugar in it
you'd make salad you know before
wishbone then huh yeah I don't know
about that maybe but I think Hidden
Valley they took their ranch powder and
they were just like what doesn't make
the bottled dressing of this but people
would make it up and just have it in a
little carafe on the table but nobody
was eating it like it wasn't flavoring
it I don't remember eating salads any
like without anything besides ranch
ya know ever what's up fool this week
our B&B in Schaumburg Illinois all the
shows are sold out we just added a
second show on Sunday at nine o'clock so
get those tickets
I also thank everybody who showed up and
bought those tickets ahead of time that
never happened to me ever in my life in
Schaumburg in Schaumburg where I just
showed up and other tickets are sold
said I might not even wake up for
president
the front there's a note and tell the
driver to go back to your house and
sleep bankers what are we gonna promote
one more show that's a dream right there
no press Sundays did Fridays in this
case [ __ ] what's up fool shut up to Jose
I'll help wentest Felipe going back to
Austin or yes I am bro yes end of April
at the end of last week end of April and
in March that's all you have you have
Toppenish Washington legends Casino
March six in the Midland Texas in Austin
Texas at 27th and 28th but that's part
of the big show with Bruce Bruce an
earthquake and Loney love your mother's
you think that uh since the Astros
cheated you think we could go back to
that third world country and get back
our world world champion Dodgers shirt
anybody know where we haven't been
declared the winners like that but you
think that mommy's gonna do it they're
not huh get the stuff no no you think
they're gonna declare Dodgers the winner
no they want to wear in the winter but
they may put an asterisk next to the
Astros or just sayin just a little extra
for probably take take that away I would
imagine but I don't know about stripping
a title because then the the
Commissioner baseball say it's just a
piece of metal and everybody got all
crazy cuz he said on Sunday Bellinger
talking about it cuz he was on the horse
and I heard who actually went off a
player I should say who would take back
my boos what's up with that dude the
Korea from from the Astro saying well
why are you talking if he doesn't know
all the facts we know the facts you
fools cheated dude with technology
everybody had a little video walk clear
his engagement invalidated after those
after the world they have a couple of
players like with wires in her chest
I don't know how real those are but well
that's the whole thing they're saying he
was anybody strip his jersey cuz he was
wired up yeah and I think it definitely
helps but I don't think it like to find
them winning like you really you were to
know what whether or not they would have
one shot though they really sucked and
he could give a well for that I mean
come on he choked on those he stole
everything for every player
there you go and how other players are
actually good for the Dodgers strike it
fools out like that that guy hey des
don't forget about the first game we
[ __ ] up by letting that guy get that
that young guy what was his name you uh
you know what was his last name he goes
yeah they can I know man I mean they
made really bad decisions and then of
course we were exhausted with batters
and it's so much money because somebody
said in LA Times article well the
Dodgers were all high on analytics just
uh
Houston's analytics were better yeah
yeah as ridiculous and then they're also
as to than was the are to cheated the
next year tight now yeah so it's like
analytic but the analytics things pisses
me off because yeah there's analytics
but that's like paying attention only to
your GPS and not paying attention to the
fact that you're going in circles all
you know and there can be problems okay
so she left okay yeah he was gonna be a
coach for the Dodgers but he wasn't down
with that and letting so that right now
we're good there could be analytics but
it's something else is going on on the
field you got to [ __ ] change your
game plan and what's his name come on Oh
Robert I miss company man with whatever
the the top brass or the management's it
what's up fool we have shows coming up
your shows and rumor saying we don't
have a we don't have a venue right now
and I'm trying to do something with the
improv
the venue dude there's just something
going on with it's not the same
management as before yeah it's a
community but the girl that was there
before kind of got fired so it's kind of
different with the scheduling and we're
all super busy but so we got to just see
what what it is we can do there and we
pretty much took the last month off so
we don't have a definite date if we're
gonna bring it back that way once a
month and that was a cool venue though
so that's looking for another one
what's our pool taking everybody who
showed up to Visalia California two
sold-out shows they were freaking
amazing friends now and also Fresno two
sold-out shows thank you everybody who
showed up shout out to the whole meal
Leonard my last guest 72 years old I
thought oh yeah yeah probably go I will
give you some advice Carlos don't get
old I'll try not to it
every time every time I go to Visalia
before my cell yeah man how are the
redwoods I never been here before the
redwood forest the forest Sequoia cool
huge well there was that little the
little mini redwood they have right
there by selling ice to the post office
they're huge huh they're enormous dawg
they're like it's unbelievable do you
like when you see them even watch
anything new on Netflix beside what
everybody watching no open watching
shrill is back
really it ended too fast to win it for
penis I think they said they got renewed
they just didn't have a I think sure to
Orlando Maldonado he's happy Don Jose
uncle went this Margot Sandoval do you
give him happy birthday happy birthday
happy time a capital happy birthday -
happy / Colorado Springs is not on the
schedule right now no Colorado yet oh
the forum giggle Colorado's breathe when
I'm with you no never been there yeah
you went there one time I think Oh web
nowhere
no I think restore and open for you
Colorado Springs no no never been there
no where to Pueblo or Pueblo or
somewhere I'll find it maybe him me and
him are selling went to a little town
near there but it was not Colorado
Springs yeah but I think you went there
with haha after but it was the comedy
works no matter would like Russell
Peters or something no the Denver comedy
work so how many works you did tell our
Springs to there's another there's a
place you went it was a while a long
time ago your with APA I think yeah but
that wonderful mood that little-ass
Airport word that brother had was good
he did know how to roll he didn't know
how to roll the burritos but his the
beautiful summer of that it was
everything was remember they were giving
Larry trouble because his name was
Lawrence on the but not Larry I know it
was like a Colorado yeah that Ignacio I
don't know when I went to the casino
what's up boo thank you very much for
listening to the wonderful podcast come
back next week where they have a whole
new guest with a nice yes
next week is reverie remember II love
the little chore lead the who rats from
Hilah bark she'll be with a brother I
think she's just by herself her brother
doesn't do much public stuff much of
Rizzo be back people also madam so I
mentioned in that factory March 4th
March 3rd Laugh Factory is coming up
that it will be English but it's not
your full show it's just you're doing a
set on the minute 1609 and on March 6
Sunday it's a Spanish show at the ice
house but again that's not your full
show you're doing 15 20 minute set so
what's up to Frank Avila the 3rd Jose
Quintero
Pepe what's up anybody else
[Laughter]